les annales judiciaires la sphère
grégory occupe une place à part elle a
profondément marqué toute une génération
de journalistes de magistrats une
affaire aux multiples dysfonctionnements
où beaucoup ont perdu le sens commun et
20 ans jour pour jour après la mort du
petit grégory retrouvé ligoté 108 dans
un ruisseau le mystère subsiste gringo
métier la photo a marqué tous les
esprits
l'enfant paraît endormi c'est un petit
cadavre entravé que porte ce pompier
celui de grégory villemin 4 ans et demi
noyé dans la vologne depuis le 16
octobre 1984 cette vallée humide des
vosges est le théâtre d'une énigme qui a
tué le petit grégory les lettre d'un
corbeau mène tout d'abord les enquêteurs
vers le cousin de jean marie villemin
bernard laroche et écroué après le
témoignage accablant de sa belle-soeur
villemin laroche des journalistes se
passionne pour cette guerre des clans
vraiment ennuyeux fait du coup c'est
docteur jekyll mr est c'est à dire que
de façade il est bien mais d'intérieur
il est complètement pourri premier d'une
longue série de rebondissements la
belle-soeur de bernard laroche se
rétracte ya un jeu dans lequel avait la
voix et puis j'ai eu peur du mot dit
alors j'avais fait ça et gimont qui
pareille
bernard hinault 100 nouveaux frais les
aînés sont montrés du doigt le juge
lambert accusée de ne privilégier qu'une
seule thèse et légendes à trop proche de
la presse on en est exactement au même
point qu'à midi et que hier il ya deux
jours malheureusement si jamais vous
pouvez nous aider
l'aide des journalistes aura des effets
désastreux sur l'anc est à la libération
de bernard laroche les soupçons du juge
glisse vers christine villemin mais pour
son mari il n'y a aucun doute dans
l'opinion deux camps s'affrontent
c'est trop de pression pour jean marie
villemin qui décide de se faire justice
et abat son cousin
trois mois plus tard christine villemin
était inculpée de l'assassinât de son
fils il faudra huit ans la justice pour
finalement innocenté la mère de grégory
et reconnaître entre autres erreurs son
impuissance à trouver la vérité jean
marie villemin lui a purgé sa peine de
trente quatre mois de détention
vingt ans après la mort de grégory ses
parents ont quitté les vosges en menant
avec les cendres de leur fils
aujourd'hui à lépanges il ne reste rien
si ce n'est un secret au fond de la
vologne
[Musique]